(slow classical music)
- [Woman] Greta is a 16-year-old girl
who has inspired thousands
maybe even millions of people
to stand up for both
themselves and the climate.
- [Girl] She thought
everything was going in
the wrong direction.
And now she's become a
really big role model
for a lot of people.
- [Girl] I look up to her a
lot 'cause I think it's so cool
what she's doing.
- [Girl] It's time that
we actually stood up
for the climate and did something instead
of just sitting around.
(slow classical music)
- The climate crisis is
the biggest crisis
humanity has ever faced.
And yet it has been ignored for decades.
The older people usually
say that we owe it to the young people
to give them hope.
But we don't want you to be hopeful,
we want you to panic.
They say that they love their children
above all else,
and yet they are stealing their future
in front of their very eyes.
The leaders who know that change is coming
whether they like it or not.
- [Announcer] One in four
Americans is skeptical
of all the effects of climate change
and thinks this issue's been exaggerated.
- Environmental annihilation is coming
because we've been evil.
- Do you know what this is?
It's a snowball.
- Some people don't believe
in the climate crises,
they don't understand that it's real.
And I have to say
that I understand them
in a way because in the beginning
when I first found out about
this I doubted that it was true.
Because if it was true,
then we wouldn't be talking
about anything else.
That would be our first priority.
But it's not.
People say it's like an abstract threat
in the future, but it's happening now;
we can already see the changes.
We already have increased the temperature
above pre-industrial levels 1.2 degrees.
And everything's happening very fast now.
We need to do something
and act as if we were in a crisis
because otherwise people won't understand
that we are in a crisis.
- So Greta thanks to be with us, hi.
You said many times I was like
an invisible girl before.
But now you are very famous,
everybody is here with you,
and they want you for the Nobel prize.
How did you reach this point?
- In August,
last year I decided that this was enough.
I sat myself down on the ground outside
the Swedish parliament.
And I school-striked for the climate.
I have said that I will
continue to school strike
every Friday until Sweden is
in line with the Paris agreements.
That may take a long time.
I will have to be patient
and to remind myself
of why I'm doing this.
The symbolism of the school strike is
that since you adults don't give a damn
about my future I won't either.
Why should we care for our future
when we might not have one?
And why should we bother
to learn facts when facts
don't matter in this society.
It's absurd that young people will have
to skip school.
And risk their own education
because they are scared
of not having a future.
And I think that is a very strong message.
- You have heard about
a Greta Thunburg.
- Greta Thunburg.
- Greta Thunburg,
thank you very much for
joining us this morning.
- At first I was all alone
and then people started joining me.
And then it started
spreading to different places
and then different countries
and then different continents.
And then it became global.
In December the UN had
a climate change conference,
and there I held some speeches.
We have run out of excuses
and we are running out of time.
I think that was also
when more people started
to found out about the school strikes.
And then at the end of
January I was invited
to the World Economic Forum.
Our house is on fire.
And also there I held a speech,
which also went I think viral
and those two I think,
both those two were tipping
points of this movement.
It has just escalated.
And it's going so fast
like I can't even keep
up with it anymore.
Now there is hundreds of thousands
of children who are striking
from school for their future.
(children chanting)
(speaking foreign language)
When I was 11,
I became very depressed.
I stopped eating and I stopped talking
and I stopped going to school.
It had a lot to do with
the climate and the environment.
I started making changes
in my own life.
Like stop flying,
stop eating meat and dairy.
And stop buying new things.
In order to be able to look myself
in the eye.
I need to do something myself.
I started talking with my parents.
After awhile they decided
to do that as well.
Before I started the school strike I was
that person who was invisible.
I never spoke unless I had to.
And also I have Asperger's syndrome.
I'm a bit different
from everyone else.
When you have Asperger's
you also tend to have
the capacity of being very focused
and interested in some subjects.
And that allowed me to focus
on one thing for a very long time.
I think that if I wouldn't have
had Asperger's I don't
think I would have started
the school strike.
And I don't think I would
have been interested
in the climates at all.
Because if I would have
been like everyone else
I'd just continued like
before not thinking twice
about this, but now I can't do that.
My conscious doesn't allow me to do that.
(suspenseful music)
(children chanting)
I think this movement
could become very big;
and I think that we have
just seen the beginning
because more and more people are going
to start realize the
emergency of the situation,
and they will get angry.
And they will want to
do something about it,
especially young people who
will understand eventually
that their future is
being taken from them.
Many people say that we are too young
to do this,
we shouldn't do this.
And I agree,
we shouldn't have to do this.
But in the situation we are in now.
We feel like we have to do this
because we won't accept
you risking our future.
If the adults won't take responsibility,
then we will have to.
(slow classical music)